hemos visto ya un par de ejemplos de
cómo balancear ecuaciones y vimos que si
tratamos de balancear esta ecuación
deberíamos empezar con las moléculas más
complicadas por ejemplo en el vídeo
anterior vimos que si empezábamos con el
carbono verdad aquí teníamos 2 carbonos
mientras que del lado derecho teníamos
sólo un carbono verdad teníamos 2 por el
etileno mientras que del lado derecho
teníamos sólo 1 por el dióxido de
carbono y la pregunta que podría uno
hacerse es porque porque podríamos poner
este 2 digamos de este el coeficiente
digamos porque lo ponemos del lado
izquierdo y además grande y no a lo
mejor por ejemplo como un subíndice
digamos que fuera de esta forma y lo que
pasa es que si nosotros lo ponemos como
un subíndice ya no sería la misma
molécula verdad estaríamos cambiando la
reacción cuando estamos balanceando una
reacción
la reacción o la ecuación describe algo
que ocurre verdad algo que ocurre en el
mundo natural cuando no está balanceada
al sol o no lo que pasa es que solo no
tiene las cantidades apropiadas en
términos del número de moléculas verdad
no podemos cambiar el número de átomos
en las moléculas porque entonces
estaríamos cambiando la constitución de
esta de esta sustancia verdad entonces
vamos a tratar de visualizar esto
primero ok entonces vamos a representar
visualmente cómo se ve esta molécula del
etileno ok o del eterno y realmente lo
que tenemos son dos carbonos unidos por
un enlace doble y a cada uno de esos
carbonos se le unen dos hidrógenos
entonces más o menos se ve de esta forma
ok el el oxígeno digamos el oxígeno de
atómico vamos a ponerlo así como un
oxígeno que tiene un enlace doble o
perdón quise decir la molécula
odia atómica de oxígeno verdad se ven
como dos oxígenos unidos por un enlace
doble verdad cómo se vería por ejemplo
este es el o2 como se vería el dióxido
de carbono pues sería un carbono verdad
que tiene un enlace doble con el oxígeno
y otro enlace doble con el otro oxígeno
muy bien y finalmente tenemos el agua ok
que tendríamos un oxígeno unido a dos
hidrógenos muy bien y si te interesa
saber por qué ocurre en este tipo de
enlaces bueno te recomiendo que chequen
los vídeos de química orgánica ok
entonces ya tenemos está representado
visualmente esta reacción y fácilmente
podemos ver aquí por ejemplo en el
bióxido de carbono nosotros queríamos
ver así que qué pasaría si nosotros
ponemos c 2 o 2 entonces nosotros
estaríamos cambiando completamente la
estructura de esta molécula verdad de
alguna forma tendría que acomodar otro
carbono que se estuviera
con las otras los otros tres átomos pero
bueno queda claro que entonces
estaríamos cambiando la sustancia y ya
no sería la misma reacción lo que vamos
a hacer o lo que hemos estado haciendo
es cambiar el número de moléculas que
tenemos de cada una de ellas por ejemplo
si aquí teníamos el el el etileno verdad
y tiene dos carbonos y yo necesito del
lado de los productos dos carbonos
podríamos poner aquí un dos verdad que
esto nos diría que tenemos dos moléculas
de dióxido de carbono entonces aquí
pondría la otra molécula de dióxido de
carbono
ahora bien si nosotros tenemos ya cuatro
hidrógenos del lado de los reactivos y
del lado derecho sólo tenemos dos
entonces podríamos poner dos moléculas
de agua verdad esto sería poner aquí
otra molécula de agua y entonces ahora
si ya tenemos cuatro hidrógenos y
finalmente nosotros tenemos del lado
derecho dos hidrógenos perdón dos
oxígenos por el agua y cuatro oxígenos
por el dióxido de carbono entonces
necesitamos
o dos para tener seis oxígenos verdad
entonces tenemos ahí dos y aquí tres
entonces ahora del lado izquierdo ya
tenemos seis oxígenos verdad y ya
estamos balanceados tenemos el lado
izquierdo dos carbonos y del lado
derecho dos carbonos del lado izquierdo
cuatro hidrógenos y del lado derecho
cuatro hidrógenos del lado izquierdo
tenemos seis oxígenos y del lado derecho
tenemos cuatro oxígenos por el dióxido
de carbono y dos oxígenos por el agua
entonces ya estamos balanceados y
observar no hemos cambiado la estructura
interna de la molécula simplemente
cambiamos el número de moléculas que
tenemos y eso es lo que representan los
coeficientes del lado izquierdo de estas
moléculas